- So, you're being controlled
by someone on Netflix?
What is Netflix, is it a planet?
- I don't know really.
Some sort of future entertainment thing.
- Like a computer game?
- I don't know.
It's from the 21st century they said.
- Okay, well let's try to
pick it apart logically
and see if we can define if
this is reality or delusion.
- It's not a delusion.
- Okay, let's go through it.
Okay, so all of this is
happening to entertain someone.
Someone who's controlling you.
- Uh-huh.
- So why aren't you in a
more entertaining scenario?
- What do you mean?
- Well look at you.
You're in a small, ordinary room,
in an ordinary part of the world,
talking to an ordinary woman.
If this was entertainment,
surely you'd make it more interesting,
inject a little action, isn't that right?
I mean, wouldn't you
want a little more action
if you were watching this now on telly?
(tense electronic music)
(tea splashes)
(therapist screams)
(objects smash and clatter)
Come at me, come on mummy's boy.
What are you waiting for?
(music intensifies)
Come on, I dare you.
(therapist shouts)
(kick thuds)
(glass smashes)
(both grunt)
(therapist screams)
(fists thud)
(music intensifies)
(both grunt)
- How's that for entertainment,
you psychiatric fuck?
Huh?
Fucked your day up good
and proper, didn't we?
Me and my friend from the future! (laughs)